hey youtubers is Charlie since everyone
is flipping out about thinking bran is
not gonna be in season 5 of Game of
Thrones I'm gonna do an explainer video
to talk about what's going on what was
said and what it might mean for the show
so Kristian Nairn who plays Hodor on the
show is on tour right now for his rave
it's like a game of Thrones theme brave
he did an interview where he basically
said he has an entire year off and
people are taking that to mean everyone
in his party will not be in season 5
like there will not be any brand scenes
at all so really what happened is he
said like a really off handed thing and
then it became a telephone game where
people just kept repeating and
interpreting what other people said you
know versus going back to the original
quote the original interview says almost
nothing about Season 5 it's just this
one sentence that he said an HBO thus
far has refused to comment actually
that's not true
MTV claims that HBO replied with Hodor I
don't know if that's true or not if they
were just making a joke so let's start
with the actual interview the part that
cost everyone to crap their pants went
like this
Naren said and this is straight from
this quote we have a season off and we
have a year's hiatus solely because I
imagine our storyline is up to the end
of the books so I get a year off now to
do the rave of Thrones and galavant all
over the world that's basically all I
said so what this means is is that Hodor
definitely is not in season 5 he has all
season to do his tour it's the Wii part
that is making everyone think that he
meant everyone in Brants party or at
least the ones that are still alive
under normal circumstances you think the
interviewer talking to him would have
followed up on it they might be like hey
let me get this straight you bran Mira
the child of the forest the three-eyed
Raven they're not doing any of those
scenes with those characters at all but
that's not the case that's not what
ended up happening they didn't follow up
on it that's why I'm not a huge fan of
celebrity interviews you know
celebrities tend to say a lot of things
without saying anything it's only
because they're under contract to HBO
and they would get sued out of existence
for spoiling a season so I can only
imagine the angry phone calls that
Kristian Nairn is getting right now from
their PR department so whatever but here
are a couple things that this could mean
so right off the bat let's assume no
Hodor since he's gonna be on tour Isaac
Hempstead right does not have any other
projects he's working on right now so
unless we see him shooting another movie
or a TV show somewhere else
the next couple of months he could still
shoot some warding or some flashback
scenes so quick spoiler warning for
Brandt's character in book 5 I'm just
gonna have to explain a little bit to
give some more context so I'll leave the
little spoiler tag up while the spoilers
are going on you could just skip to you
don't see the spoiler tag anymore okay
everybody ready here we go so bran
spends his time learning about the green
side during book 5 and learns that he
can use the weirwood trees to I guess
you could call it see back in time he
can't see forward but he can see
anything in the field of vision of a
weirwood tree for as long as it's been
alive so for instance he could peep on
Ned Stark whenever he was a child
whenever Ned start with a child as long
as he was sitting underneath the
godswood he can see in any of the gods
woods in any of the other castles in
Westeros as long as the trees though we
were trees still exist there a lot of
them have been cut down where we are in
the story right now so basically all of
his story in book 5 or most of it at
least is spent learning how to use this
ability with the three-eyed Raven
like he said stationary in his cave
there so the big question is is why
would they cut him out it's possible if
it's true that he's not in season 5 that
the producers felt like watching bran
sit stationary under that tree and do
flashbacks all year would just slow down
the pace of the season okay so spoilers
over so the producers in HBO might just
be choosing to focus on the big action
scene so just stay away from things they
feel might slow the pace down
they've already been several spoilery
scenes filmed or being prepared to film
I'll totally talk about them in other
videos if you guys want but they
involved you know Cersei Jaime the
Martel's Tyrion Sir Jorah
Daenerys I mean I guess I've mentioned
pretty much everybody on the show but
let's just say there's gonna be as many
oh moments as there were in season
4 if you guys want I'll talk about them
all in like a couple spoilery videos
just let me know in the comments
remember they even cook Gendry out of
season 4 completely just because he
didn't have any big epic action scenes
and they all but cut bran out of season
4 - like bran was barely in last season
anyway so next big question if they do
cut him out how would they bring him
back in like how would they explain his
absence so they could either condense
the flashback moments that he has to a
single scene or just cut them out
entirely and just have him reference
them in past tense like pickup with bran
and the story being a fully actualized
greenseer
so since when the winner has not been
we really don't know a whole lot about
brand story aside from what we hear in
prophecies and what we hear other
characters say but we do know he'll be
working with the children of the forest
because they're all green seers and he's
learning to be green seer in the great
conflicts of the past the children have
fought for the balance of nature so
they're like a neutral party for example
it's implied they use the hammer of
waters to shatter the arm of Dorne
when the first men invaded Westeros then
during the long night the children were
the ones that discovered White Walkers
were vulnerable to obsidian they went
out to make a new truce with the first
men gave them the obsidian blades and
drove the White Walkers back any time
large-scale magics get involved in the
climate changes the children reappear
and work to balance things also another
good example during my religions and
gods video that I did last week I put
forth the example that if dragons were
to overpopulate like if Daenerys has
dragons over populated the earth the
world would start to overheat the
children would resurface and work to
bring balance back also vice-versa if
things got too cold again so really
which side bran ends up helping just
depends on where the balance of the
climate is it's implied that winter is
coming so it is implied that he'll be
working against the White Walkers even
though there are rumors to say otherwise
I just said that because during current
events Melisandre supposedly has a
vision implying that the three-eyed
Raven serves the great other the finale
last year kind of contradicts that
because the skeletons can't enter the
cave like his cave is designed so that
the forces of the great other cannot
enter it so why would he be working with
them if he can't enter the cave it just
supports the idea that they're a neutral
third party between roller and the great
other brain will be working with them so
whatever ends up happening he could
totally wind up fighting against or with
his old friends and family again at
least the ones that are still alive
since it's pretty clear that the show is
probably not going to do any of these
implied big final battles they might
just bring him back whenever they're
ready to deal with that like whenever
the White Walkers are ready to attack
the wall I am working on a new winds of
winter video where I'll talk more about
some of these spoiler things I do have
some ideas about when the White Walkers
will attack the wall so be sure to
subscribe to get that the giveaway is
still running - I'll announce a winner
whenever I post my next Q&A video after
the faith militant video I'm working on
all you do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video that
faith built a video be
the next one to post I just posted this
video because everyone was crapping
their pants all over social media so
right now you can learn more about my
white Walker theories here and you can
click here to learn more about my top 5
favorite prophecies in general so thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives
[Music]